Ellen how are you I have mark on the
phone do you want to talk to him are
there no here I'm gonna give you this
let me give you like all the attention
no he hates it he just you know be out
of the limelight what does it mean to
get the carol burnett award and be the
first person to get it out of all the
people on the planet what does it mean
to you I mean it obviously would have
meant more to me to get it before Carol
but she got it first yeah it's it's a
it's a lot it's it's really she's she's
you know somebody that I was you know
crazy about growing up and so to have my
name next to her name in any form is
amazing she said you guys had dinner
just the other night yeah yeah yeah so
you hang with Carol did you I do know
Carol we're we're pals yes yeah
did you lobby at all did you say Carol
listen if you want this to work mate
actually I thought that she picked me
and she was surprised that they picked
me so it was a hard Hollywood Foreign
Press so shout out to them thank you so
much yes can you do us a favor
it is our 10,000th episode coming up
this week it is a shout out we've done
10,000 episodes we don't get residuals
but we got 10,000 10,000 episodes shout
out to ten thousand episodes et yeah
thank us right yeah we appreciate that
by the way how do you party tonight
after getting the Carol Burnett bird
award I'm not sure I needed to find my
wife I lost her I need to get back out
to the audience you should go see her
all right and one last thing Rwanda we
went to Rwanda have you are you going
back anytime soon to check on the grills
are when are you going back and what are
you doing I'm building a campus they're
going of course I am I'm going back when
my campus is built I'll be back there
very soon and and yeah I'm going back
this summer I'm going back all the time
okay can we go with you no okay you have
to go by yourself I mean I'll see you
there but I can't take you
oh you can't take us no okay you can go
but we can go you can go whenever you
want yeah we want to go with you yeah
and Mark and the kids yeah you know yeah
how does a marking the kids are not
they're separate okay
so congratulations
[Music]